heavy gunfire has been reported in
cities in Sudan the U.S ambassador to
Sudan John Godfrey says that he and his
staff are Sheltering in the embassy
after those clashes broke out at the UK
Embassy has also urged British Nationals
to stay indoors well joining us now is
our Africa correspondent yusra elbagher
uh yusra good to see you
um it's been a precarious situation in
Sudan anyway of recent times just
explain to us how things are looking
today
I mean it's been a very intense day in
the capital but also across the country
fighting broke out in the morning
gunfire Was Heard across hartum by
residents who weren't able to leave
their homes and that continued and sort
of spiraled throughout the day at the
moment there's ongoing fighting at the
airport where forces are trying to seize
control and there's also ongoing
fighting around the presidential Palace
now these are key sites and whichever
Force manages to take over these sites
they will essentially have political
power over the country when you look at
the presidential Palace but also the
airport which is currently unable to
operate people aren't able to come in
and out so there is a halt in sort of
the day-to-day operations in the country
at the moment and just to talk a little
bit about the two sides that are
fighting you've got the Sudanese Armed
Forces which are essentially governing
the country in the post-revolution
period after long time military dictator
Ahmad Bashir was ousted and you've got
the paramilitary group the rapid support
forces the rsf that came into Power
after the conflict in that Ford it's a
medley of tribal militias that have been
accused used of committing atrocities in
dive forward and we're deeply empowered
by bashir's government as he tried to
crush the Rebellion there over the last
two decades now these forces have
essentially come into power shared power
since the revolution they Consolidated
their power during a pact in 2021 during
a coup and the but tensions have been
building behind the scenes especially
over the last few days where the Army
has come out and called the rapid
support forces movement a clear
violation of law not in coordination
with the Army and essentially moving in
its own interests people are really
scared there's a low-flying military
aircraft gunfire is continuing they're
seeing anti-aircraft
artillery on the streets and they're
asking why the International Community
hasn't come in these are these are
powers the U.S the UK Europe who have
been mediation powers during the
post-revolution transition period when
they're asking why they haven't come in
to sort of intervene and quell what
could become a civil war this is what
the U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken had to say
the
the major parties in in cartoon some
weeks ago reached a very important
framework agreement on how to proceed
with a transition to civilian government
and there's been real progress in trying
to move that forward
it's a
it's a fragile situation
there are
other actors that maybe
pushing against that that progress but
this is a real opportunity
to finally carry forward the
civilian-led transition and one that we
and other countries
are trying to to bolster
I mean it's important to note that both
sides of this of these classes have been
accused of committing atrocities against
unarmed pro-democracy protesters in the
last few years and now they're fighting
so civilians are are deeply scared and
uncertain about what could happen if
there isn't a very efficient and
effective intervention
you sir well we've got you um some
fairly dramatic footage appearing on
social media showing planes at some of
the main airports in Sudan on fire
reports
um unconfirmed reports of civilians
being injured in those explosions as
well
yeah I mean we've we've been hearing of
civilians pouring into hospitals reports
of injuries of casualties we're unclear
of how many people have been hurt we'll
know probably towards the end of the day
but this is this is why it spread and it
is deeply deeply worrying deeply
concerning
all right yusra thank you